je fais comme très naturel tu meures
touche pas les réseaux sociaux on m'a
toujours dit que j'étais pareil voire
mieux en vrai je pense que sur les
réseaux sociaux à part la luminosité et
la couleur je change pas grand chose et
je pense pas qu'il sera déçu ou quoi que
ce soit non je pense que je pourrais lui
perd je me fais pas de souci pourtant on
le sait bien les photos peuvent décevoir
car elle ne reflète pas toujours bien la
réalité espérons que pierre soit
agréablement surpris en la découvrant en
vrai
alors la peau est si faible foncé sur
les réseaux
c'est injuste moi je trouve parce que
d'abord elle est beaucoup mieux en vrai
et ensuite on lui fait payer bah oui
allait beaucoup mieux en vrai regardez
comme elle est nature mais pourquoi vous
riez allait beaucoup mieux en vrai
regardez elle est expressive alors que
là les retoucher et elle subit la
dictature des réseaux sociaux ah bah ça
vous fait rire garder à gauche allait
magnifique sublime cyril franchement
elle est beaucoup mieux en vrai pour la
dictature des réseaux sociaux il se
transforme toute la soutient totalement
nue c'est magnifique auvray magnifique
qu'est sur lee mais conduit pas lui en
vrai dans la vie
[Rires]
c'est fini c'est pas la perse
je suis la même chose sur steam d'heure
mais des photos de matthieu delormeau et
après je me pointe au rendez vous
j'étais partagé sur les sur les filles
parce que les filles ou les garçons qui
souvent
n'attire personne ou personne vient leur
parler mais à tout d'un coup on vient
alors par alain et respectant une chance
de faire quelque chose m et c'est vrai
que du coup bah voila ca progresser que
du virtuel tant truies oui non passer du
concept virtuel lorsque si j'étais un
mec et tu parles à la nana à droite tu
es chaud bouillant tu vas t'acheter la
plus belle chemise tu réserves dans le
plus beau restaurant c'est la nana à
gauche qui arrive
même pas qu'il ya des quads oui non mais
tu es très bonne année si elle c'est de
séduire et à
rester à huy bloquer le cinéma les gens
utilisent ils n'auraient même pas donnés
en est on y prend part sera mensonge
auditoire déjà gelé star je suis content
de ma phrase c'est quoi séduire avec le
mensonge on aime avec la vérité
séduits avec le mensonge on aime avec la
vérité oui ça plutôt
séduite avec quelqu'un et tout ça tu te
dis tout ce que l'autre envie de ne pas
vous connaissez vraiment eu débat en
fait ce n'est pas complètement vrai
qu'imaginer femme de castaldi arrêté sur
ces fouilles il fait le va pas lui
laisser il va pas lui laisser le temps
mathieu ils veulent arriver il va tomber
le beau tout sinon le torse rien
précisément en fait c'est pour ça que
vous levez la main ça va mieux on s'aime
après quand on se découvre que ça t'a
jamais remarqué que ce n'est pas le
temps de la découverte dans ce cas large
part de qui là de répondre
oui non mais à gauche en fait c'est une
beauté atypique et puis à droite elle
ressemble elle ressemble à tout le monde
est gros mais je suis désolé à droite
information n'a pas
l'airé bon ok ça si c'est tout le monde
non je vais partir avec des gars dans le
public mais
ressemble à toutes les filles de
télé-réalité moi je prends un visage
atypique venait de beauté atypique c'est
quoi c'est monsieur pas l'assumer un
truc là là
jamais
on dit souvent
non mais ça montre à quel point aussi il
ya une pression parce que cette aide est
obligé de même mon fils pour qu'un
garçon viennent leur lait la raison nos
clients voulaient les actifs physiques
hippiques
non mais tu passes à bourgines will a
absolument raison delphine parce qu'il
ya filtré filtre alors il ya évidemment
le côté photoshop pour on peut enlever
moi par exemple ça m'arrive j'enlève des
petits des rides pour être un petit peu
moins vieille et tout ça mais en
revanche j'ai aussi des filtres qui
formate et elle a raison c'est toujours
les mêmes formats kim kardashian télé
non non non tu connais toujours les
français vous êtes une
de malhonnête
et et gilbert neige peu plus la foudre
est énorme à arrêter
vraiment par l'âge il se fout de notre
gueule sa passation a été d'une belle à
jean tu me déminage quand la ja
paramécies la-croix com et je suis pas
un médium est demandée raymond iv ne
connais pas c'est koné vaï connais mieux
vous non là bas non pas les fossiles
fait trop les pays si on prend toutes
les filles du public et nous tout en
photo et on utilise le même filtres
comme mademoiselle on aura tout l'air
d'être comme mademoiselle râteau même
connaissez pas arrêté de faire du mytho
sinon c'est l'armée maté à rennes et
leur beauté c'est pas la même personne
si le mec voilà maintenant on n'a pas
des qualités mieux mais c'est que le mec
il haranguait le prince était principe
de l'émission c'est que voilà il parle
avec elle sur les réseaux et après la
rencontre il parle avec cette meuf
depuis juin combien de temps il ya cette
jeune fille qui arrive si c'est vrai
alors c'est une autre beauté mais c'est
pas la même chose et donner ce qu'ils
s'installent au type cyril vu avec ce
filtre là vous auriez la même tête mais
pas du tout c'est braga n'est pas
d'arrêter dire des conneries ils étaient
tous armés sème d'avant lehman il a b c
du vol un peu plus vieux
que moi ce débat est bien sûr je peux le
débat avec m non mais c'est comme sur
les cyber oui les sites de rencontres de
cuissage pâte à marietta cauchi l'époque
ce à quoi jadis jacques lycée elle
s'arrête aussi mais je cherche une
relation sérieuse
bonjour bakou désolé moi c'est pour un
plan cul te vois tu habites hockey
keller bah voilà aller où la relation
sérieuse
j'aurais jamais dû laisser que
jamais la la la la je suis je me suis
perdu